action here with reaction donald trump
jr all right a lot to digest
four major arguments in my mind one
it's unconstitutional two the snap
impeachment
was made before we found out that the
whole thing had been pre-planned
in advance three the insurrectionist
language of the left which i kind of
think is a big deal and we can get to
more your thoughts
well sean if it wasn't for double
standards the democrats would have no
standards at all i mean i think in your
monologue you sort of highlighted
all of the hypocrisy that we saw during
10 months
of rioting looting arson
in your face type of politics candidly
whatever my father said on january 6 was
mild in comparison but if you were to
take his speech
and compare it to literally any stump
speech
ever given in the history of politics
you would see absolutely no deviation
but again because the democrats have the
media
in their pocket carrying whatever
message
they can go on with impeachment part du
what they started before the original
inauguration
they're just going to continue it
they're all excited to be able to
grandstand to be able to selectively
edit to do their faux
outrage on a global scale with tv
and free air time that's what this is
all about and i think that's the way we
have to counter that
we have to do the same things we have to
fight back the way the democrats fight
and i don't mean physically because in
today's world if you say the word fight
all of a sudden magically that means
in insurrection give me a break sean
this stuff is asinine
44 republicans have already voted to say
that the sham impeachment part du
is unconstitutional aren't we in the
middle of a pandemic sean
i thought that these senators would
maybe have something better to do
maybe they would actually fight for the
american people
for a change maybe they would actually
get to the business
of helping us through this pandemic i
don't see that happening and i certainly
don't see it happening from the biden
administration who's
killing american jobs defending china
eliminating the ban of the confucius
institute which is china taking over our
universities
you know and ultimately bribing our
professors to get uh you know all the
data that you have
out of the research projects in american
universities i mean
you're opening the border you have to
test people coming in legally to the
country for covet 19 but illegal
immigrants streaming across the border
there's no tests they just get released
into society
the double standards are insane and
maybe the united states senate should be
focused on that
rather than their nonsense you know i i
know that there
are eight they're going to be two
eight-hour days available for both
the the case they want to put on i don't
know what they could possibly say
except sliced dice selectively edit
oh look at this but let's take out what
donald trump trump said to march
peacefully and patriotically we'll take
that part out
yeah um to me by your details sean
it's a minor detail yeah it's called a
fact
yeah it's actually called real words
that they didn't want that's
inconvenient for their argument
but it's not inconvenient their
insurrectionist language don jr is it
it's not in them then all of the ones i
played and many more i could go on
all night they would be guilty based on
their own
standard and yet the media is only on
one side
that's sad correct and more importantly
the republicans are also
and rightfully so i don't think we
should be impeaching
everyone in the democrat caucus who said
ridiculously i don't
either frankly much more inflammatory
than i agree that donald trump said
i'm not about that although if they're
gonna pursue these things republicans
have to stop
trying to play the game differently we
gotta play
hardball if they're playing hardball
we've been playing t-ball for
generations
while the democrats have played hardball
we've turned the other cheek as they've
slapped us in the face
and laughed as they've won every major
fight along the way
while we claim some sort of moral high
ground and losing everything
that's what donald trump showed the
republican party that you can push back
that you don't have to go with their
norms that you don't have to listen to
the media when they're just flagrantly
putting out nonsense
you can actually push back and i hope
that the republican party does that
if they go back to the old ways of just
rolling over
and dying each and every time someone in
the media wants to write a mean piece
about them because they can't stand
them or their constituents or donald
trump 75 million people
that voted for him in this country the
highest of any conservative
in the history of america you know
there's no future for the party
so they better learn from that and as
much as i despise the notion of it
we have to be playing the same game so
we got to come out aggressively we got
to pursue those kind of ideas
if they're going to do it it's the same
with cancel culture notice
that only goes one way i'm not for
cancel culture but if they're going to
use it against
us against half of the country
on a daily basis and use it to get rid
of people to suppress them to bully them
and it's bullying in so many cases you
know if they come after me it's one
thing i got a platform i'm a big boy
when they go after some of these people
that don't have any platform they try to
attack them as cnn has done
with random people who post something on
facebook you know that kind of bullying
has to stop and we have to push back
accordingly look what's happening it's
cancelled culture
oh have you are you or have you ever
been a supporter of donald trump
re-education camps they won't hire
people that
serve their country in the white house
oh don jr might buy a house in the
neighborhood
oh i get the vapors oh the feigned
outrage
it is literally it is the sickest it's
ever been ever
it really is i mean it's mccarthyism on
steroids
i mean think about it this way i mean
they're doing this across the board but
even within the military
if you have conservative leanings we're
going to be purged well i don't know
i called a couple friends you know of
mine you know in the seal teams
you know how many guys do you think
would lean left in the teams
you know they go about maybe one percent
and they'd be really really moderate on
just about everything so this notion of
purging conservatives from the military
for
i mean what are they protecting i mean
these people have to represent
americans this is half of the country
that they're talking about
trying to cancel trying to suppress and
guess what
this is the kind of treatment and
behavior that created the rise of donald
trump
and i think we're going to see that push
back in midterms because as always
the democrats are over playing their
hand
they don't get it because they live in
their little echo chambers
and i understand the irony of the son of
a billionaire from manhattan
having a better pulse of the american
people than the people
chosen by those people to represent them
in congress
but the congress is clueless the
democrats in congress have no idea
what's going on
because they have their lackeys in the
media telling them they're right about
all of their nonsensical attacks
all right why don't you go to congress
and argue with david shone you
you'd be the perfect guy all right don
jr thank you
all right